Hey Allen, how's it going? That's
great. How are you? Pretty good.
Can I ask you six or seven
questions? Yeah, sure. Go for it.
What's one application of
plots of computing that
you're most excited about so
it could fall diagnosis.
Do you miss MIT? Uh,
sometimes I need to be
politically correct here.
Favorite part of the
software stack? Oh, I love,
so first of all, I love the tools, right?
And making it easy for developers to be
able to rate code in the quantum system.
I love that. What's one thing
you really like about Vancouver?
How the view from my apartment,
this is amazing.
Overlooking Coal Harbor in the mountains.
Where did the name D Wade come from?
I have no clue.
What do you do to relax?
I fly.
I'm a pilot.
Will quantum computing replace
classical computing? Uh,
it will probably always
work synergistically with
classic computer classical
computing through hybrid
algorithms and applications.
Last thing you made with your hands.
Uh, some gesture I'm sure. Next.
Probably while I was driving.
Next problem you want to solve?
Uh,
um, you know, I am really impressed
how next problem I want to solve.
Oh,
delivering our next generation processor.
What advice would you give
yourself 10 years ago?
Uh,
do exactly what you ended up doing
over the 10 years that followed.
What website you waste time on.
Don't waste a lot of time on websites.
I uh,
right now I'm spending all my time looking
at the monitoring system for the new
leap service and I love being there.
Last person you've emailed
it was, uh, somebody
who reports to me about,
um,
doing some planning work.
You get an all expenses paid trip to
one city. Where do you go? Bora Bora.
Would you visit Mars?
Uh,
know what to take too long to get there.
I love my family.
What is one thing you can't
live without? Diet, Dr Pepper.
What's one thing people often
misunderstand about computers?
Anyway,
this is our lab a he wave systems.
I've been trying to avoid your question.
Um,
but people often misunderstand
about quantum computers. Um,
uh,
I believe quantum computers are going
to solve real commercial problems or at
least pieces of real commercial
problems sooner than most people think,
but they're not gonna do it by solving
problems that are intractable classically
by being able to solve existing problems
that can be solved through existing
classical computers,
but just more efficiently.
What text editor do you use?
Word
Open source library that
you really like? Uh, yeah,
the uh, ocean tool suite from Dui.
What's one of your favorite movies?
Uh, I always liked air force one
and my, now I'm giving away my age.
What is something you do to come
up with project ideas? Yeah,
just think about the marketplace and what
customers are telling us they want or
need. Can we take some steps inside?
Yeah, please. Your hobbies outside of
flying,
that's flying an airplane.
Not any other form of light.
What is the first program
you've ever made? Um,
it was a synthetic aperture radar
program when I was back in college.
Professor, uh, that was a while ago.
My thesis advisor run revisted am I take
ideal culture in one word?
Yeah.
An ideal culture team,
team oriented culture,
best advice you've ever received.
Um,
go for it.
Okay.
You think you need a phd to do quantum
developing now will the singularity,
I don't think you need a master's degree
if you're a good python program program
or you can program the d system.
What's your spirit animal?
Okay.
I don't know.
Favorite Linux?
Uh,
whichever one we're using with Dua.
What's something you've
learned in the past?
Okay.
MMM.
So we just had our customer conference
and there were 20 new applications that
our customers have developed.
Everyone of those applications
was interesting and
something new that I learned
and are sorry. Ah, okay.
I was a Nerd,
any rd nerd and I was proud of it.
What resource do you use the most to
learn about the latest breakthroughs?
Uh,
I mean the web.
What's something that excites you
about the future? Quantum computing.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is a learning resource
you would use alert.
Okay.
Oh,
I would go to leap the new cloud service
from Dua of the new quantum application
environment,
which has all the training materials you
need to learn about quantum computing.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
Wow.
Uh, I don't really feel like
I've done anything brave.
What is the meaning of life?
Okay.
Uh, you know what a family,
uh, you know, just my wife,
my kids family. Look, it's the
last thing that frustrated you.
Okay.
MMM.
When we pushed an update to the leap
service prior to lines and there was some
changes in it that I wasn't
made aware of it ahead of time.
You've got frustrated me.
Name one person you really admire.
Um,
my wife,
what's the most beautiful
thing in the world? My wife.
What are the people you've met
at Bonton conferences? Like,
okay.
It depends on the conference. Um, you
know, sometimes their investors, uh,
sometimes there are
physicists and mathematicians.
Sometimes there are hardcore engineers,
sometimes it's developers.
It depends on the conference. What's
a music genre you're currently into?
I mean for me it's the 60s in the 70s.
Again,
my age cause that we have to keep
coming back to that. Oh No, no. In fact,
that was the last question.
Great. Awesome. Well thank
you so much. My pleasure.
It was great. It's a fun, fun thing.